[Musique]
j'étais sur une idée de start up
ces switchs solide évidemment qu'il
s'est planté avec son application
je vais finir bouchons mais j'ai eu un
feeling qu'il fallait que j'aille vers
quelque chose de plus fort
le cannabis va être légalisés sa tournée
dégénère c'est de l'un des leurs
l'innovation cas l'échangé de la
boucherie hazan devient la boucherie
hazan mon père il était très chaud je
gardais tournée de passe ou ça vous
pensez qu mais ma soeur à la croire moi
direct et tout m'était tursz auprès de
coûts des mamies ma mère est ce une
histoire cadre légal crop les millions 5
[Musique]
et voilà comme ça
main dans la main une cata dans la bonne
humeur familiale on s'est lancé dans un
business d'avenir
[Musique]
j'étais présente à face à wii fit
j'avais une boucherie non je plutôt bien
papa c'est aller les vilains il est
catastrophique 1 mais il était temps
d'innover cannabis ils ont légalisé
c'est de taper fort c'est vrai cadre
illégal reprend très fort des millions
sac à main
[Musique]
bush reconverti quoi jeter présente pas
sa wii substrat fuite